my name is Michael McCary creative
director of Perry Ellis we are at New
York Fashion Week men's about to see the
parallel show we went with more of a
natural look I don't think it makes
sense to be prescriptive about her
makeup on each guy is so if they have
curly hair we're going with the curls
and straight hair we're going with a
straight
we just blow-dried that we didn't use
any combs we didn't use any brushes with
our hands and our fingers we just use a
blow dryer to dry it and then we used a
powder spray the powder grip to add kind
of a more texture to it and less shine
it's fairly easy I would just towel dry
my hair after a shower once it's dry add
a little bit of the powder all over mess
it up with your hands I wouldn't use
combs I wouldn't use brushes just with
your own hand one of my favorite
suggestions is softening lotion this is
something that adds humectants and a
beautiful amount of emollients to the
skin while feeling really lightweight
and over time it helps with evening up a
tone of the skin so this is a good one
to try also don't be afraid of oil it's
important after you exfoliate that you
add as much hydration as possible so the
skin plumps up this is the way that I
like to keep dark skin looking really
fresh yet matte
when you're working on a beautiful
darker skin tone with this first of all
why mess with perfection it's just about
controlling the the texture and one of
the best ways to do that is using Mac
prep and prime skin refine zone just get
a little bit of it on your the back of
your hand and then you just take it
right over the face it instantly takes
down shine and what's left behind is
just a really beautiful silky mask in do
the right thing get good sleep drink a
lot of water and take care of yourself
and you'll look as good as this guy